well let's get the latest analysis on
the situation in the ground in ukraine
i'm joined by defense and security
analyst professor michael clark
michael love to see you so we've seen a
withdrawal of russian troops from the
north of the country uh but we've
witnessed some truly shocking scenes
haven't we what is the current situation
in the north yes
this map shows this is as of this
morning it shows how far the russians
have pulled back and how in the yellow
the ukrainians have actually occupied
the territory so it isn't just kiev
which has been relieved but churnihive
which was in a terrible state about a
week ago sumi also been relieved khaki
was even open now okay was surrounded so
these surrounded cities are now
threatened but but not surrounded and
considerable relief uh in the north but
of course we're then seeing what's being
left behind and we've got a satellite
image we can show you of one street in
butcher um now of course we've seen
these horrible images close up over the
last couple of days from our
correspondent in there deborah what does
what are these what do we think these
show
yeah these are these are maxar images
maxar is an independent satellite uh
monitoring organization it takes
photographs all over the place there's
no reason to doubt it the russians have
said that these bodies appeared after
they pulled out
maxar have shown
pretty convincingly that these bodies
lying in the street were there for quite
a long time when the russians were still
there and yesterday
the ukrainian government issued the
names and ranks and the passport numbers
of quite a lot of members of the 64th
motorized infantry brigade
and
they were the last unit to be in butcher
so there's an awful lot of dots out
there and the international community
the the uh the internet community in the
world is in a sense is being invited to
join these dots up and we'll see what
happens in the coming
weeks because we don't know what these
marks are but the marks appear to be the
size and they appear to be the angles
that we saw bodies on on the street yeah
it's fairly convincing evidence that
these bodies have been lying in the
street a long time and that they were
there when the russians were still there
when the 64th were still there
let's move on to the southeast now
russia say they're focusing their
campaign there what's happening in this
area
this is where the war is moving to the
russians very clearly
are now creating the hope and
encirclement movement of the ukrainian
forces in the area who are the best of
the ukrainian forces ultimately we're
pretty sure that they want to draw a
line from kharkiv to maliopol
literally and catch all of the
ukrainians on the wrong side of that
line if they can they will but because
they can't yet do that they're pushing
towards isiam and isiam is the center of
ukrainian resistance it has been for the
last eight years that's where most of
their forces are and they're also about
to threaten krematorsk and also
slaviansk which is very near chromatos
people are already leaving cremators
conslavians it looks as if the russians
are repositioning themselves for this
north-south movement to try to create a
line maybe not quite the line we've
indicated there but that will be their
their objective ultimately and the the
battle for the southeast is about to
begin it won't be as easy for the
russians as as they might think because
they're not as mobile as they imagine
and the ground as we've said is
softening the spring is coming on uh
their armor will have to move along
roads rather than spread out into the
country so the ukrainians will
undoubtedly take the opportunity to
attack them and they will be trying to
attack the best of the ukrainian forces
who've been dug in there very securely
for about eight years but it will be
quite a a battle as when it starts in
the coming days
okay thanks very much